patience the power of no signal improves
the main result is a cryptographic
result
about classical delegation of
computation
i will tell you what what it is about
but it also has
some quantum part or at least something
that is
might be interesting for the quantum
community uh
is that on the way to the proof we
determine
exactly the power of multiple
interactive proofs with no signaling
with a with no signaling proverbs with
no signaling strategies
and they will tell you about that too
and this is a joint work with yael
tauman kalai
for microsoft research and ron rothblum
from weitzman institute
so let me start from the problem
of computation of the of delegation of
computation
verifiable compute delegation of
computation
so what is delegation of computation
it's all classical
nothing quantum is here n is us an input
x
and she really needs to compute some
function
f of x where the best in this talk to
think of f
as a polynomially computable function
although everything that i'm going to
say scale up
up to x and i will actually talk about
it but just for now think about it as a
polynomially computable
function that is publicly known
alice really wants to compute f of x
but she has she only has a weak device
and she doesn't have enough
computational power to do that
but luckily enough bob offers to compute
f of x for alice so ali sends
x to bob bob sends back f of x to alice
and every everybody is happy so this
situation occurs today many times any
can be
just a computer that delegate the
computation to the cloud today
there are very cloud platform
services that offer to do all your
computations
and some companies don't even have
strong computers that
just have weak computers that
delegate all the computation to the
cloud or
it can be some weak device like a cell
phone that wants to
delegate computation so there are many
applications and this actually happens
today a lot
i think most of the previous papers
on the subject missed the real
application of delegation of competition
is that alice wants to delegate
computation when
she runs out of battery if she forgot to
charge her cell phone to avoid further
frustration
so what if alice doesn't trust
bob bob might be malicious
bob may have viruses in his computer
or maybe just as bugs in his computer
alice wants some guarantee that
the computation was performed correctly
and this brings us to the notion of
delegation of computation a delegation
scheme for a function
f and here i describe a one round
delegation scheme
with computational soundness and this
is the definition so alice
is the verifier from now on she's called
the verifier
also and bob is the prover so there is
some interactive proof going on here
the interactive offer has only one round
in the first round
alice sends the the input x
together one with some additional
information
that we think of a challenge or a query
and we call it q and bob answers
with the output of the function
of f on the input x so bob answers with
f of x
together with some additional
information w
that we think of as a proof that the
computation was
performed correctly and then based on
this
alice the verifier accepts or rejects
so we have the following four
requirements
from this game in order for it to be a
one-round delegation scheme
so f now is computable in time
t of n you can think of t of n as
polynomial time
or up to exponential time anything in
between
maybe the best for now to think about it
as a polynomial time but it's general
so the first two requirements are the
standard completeness and soundness
requirements that we have from
interactive proofs or
interactive arguments in this case
because their soundness is computational
so the completeness is that if p is
honest
then the probability that v accepts the
computation
is one minus something negligible almost
always
alice will accept a computation that was
done correctly by an honest over that
gives the proof correctly
the soundness requirement is
computational
it's only for a computationally bounded
a cheating prover and it says that for
any cheating proverb that runs in time
t star of n where this star you can
think of it
as polynomial or quasi-polynomial in t
maybe that's the best but it's a
parameter
for any cheating prover that runs in
time t
staff and if the computation was not
done correctly then alice rejects with
very high probability
nearly always she rejects so these are
the standard
requirements of completeness and
soundness from interactive proofs or
arguments
actually here from interactive arguments
but to this we add
two efficiency requirements
and the fishes and efficiency
requirements
are this and this first the running time
of the prover
we want it to be polynomial of t of
polynomial in t of n bob
is just a stronger computer he is not a
magician a long time ago there was a
rumor that he's a magician
called merlin but he's not a magician is
just a
stronger computer and we want bob to run
in polynomial time in time
polynomial uh of t of n
also we want the running time of alice
to be significantly smaller
than t of n we want the computation to
be delegated if
t if l is worked in time t of n
then she could have done the computation
by herself
we want this time or running time of
alice
to be much smaller and typically we want
it to be
almost linear time but surely
significantly smaller
than the time to offend say
you can be anything it's
we think of it as a challenge that the
verifier gives to the approval
as a query that uh that
just a query that the program has to
answer in order to prove
the result are there limits on the size
of w
so so then the limits are there is a
limit on the
very on the very fire well i mean the
running time of the verifier
should be small so in general we think
about
a verifier that runs in almost linear
time
but in the protocols that i will
talk about w will be even smaller than
that
you can place a limit on the
communication if you want
okay so let me tell you about uh
the previous walk for this model
uh the previous work was uh the best
previous work was by
gold vasel kalai and guy
bloom and they practically
solved actually this this scheme is also
should be scaled down for one round by a
protocol by alkaline myself
uh so actually the problem was solved
when f could be computed by a circuit of
small depth
so if f is a log space uniform circuit
of size t
and depth d then there is a one-round
delegation scheme
such that the running time of the
program is polynomial in t
and the running time of the verifier is
a field field o of n plus poly did this
hides poly logarithmic factors
so it's basically n plus polyd the
problem with this scheme
is that it depends on the depth of the
circuit
so it only works for computations that
can be done with
by a circuit with small depth so this is
the main
drawback of this protocol and
what we prove in our result uh
we give an essentially full solution for
the problem
we give a delegation scheme
for any function that in the
time t of n you can think of theophan as
polynomial
or exponential or anything in between we
give
a one-round delegation scheme such that
the running time of the proverb is
polynomial
in t of n the running time of the
verifier
is n times polylog in t and t star
i would say so it's actually the running
time of the verifier
is almost linear it's linear up to
poly logarithmic factors actually the
running time of the verifier can even be
smaller than that
it's enough that the very fire knows
one or few points in the load what is
called the low degree extension
of the input so if if the verifier knows
that
even this end can be removed so but
but otherwise the end is necessary
because the verifier must read
must read the input so using this
delegation scheme you can
delegate computation in one round and
this
only works almost linear time and she is
guaranteed
that the computation was done correctly
and the running time of the prover is
poorly
in the open all these
under exponential hardness assumptions
under
i would say standard cryptographical
assumption
it's a cryptographical protocol
because it works with the computational
soundness
in fact it matters if you go that low is
it one thing
oh that's right so but you have two
tapes right you must have told me
it's something it matters you can do it
with people
it takes two times if you want it's just
a standard algorithm
so you're asking if i need one tape or
two i don't even know but
let's say
so i didn't count the number of tapes
uh let me tell you about variant of
delegation schemes
actually the important thing is i
described
a one-round delegation scheme with
computational soundness and these are
two things that could be changed you can
you could consider one round or
interactive
scheme and you could you could consider
computational or statistical
soundness and we consider one round
scheme in the computational case one
round because it's ultimate it's better
than
interactive and computational because
usually in cryptography
people don't really care if the
soundness is computational or not and
also because it's necessary
for one round but there are many other
results about
all these four models and there are also
other results that i didn't mention
under what is called unfalsif
unfalsifiable cryptographic assumptions
and with pre-processing so there are
lots of results that i don't really
want to describe because i don't have
very much time
okay so what i want to tell you now is
about
the approach of a yellow at all
which is the which is the starting point
of our work
and this approach is based on
the multiple interactive proof model
of ben or goldwater kilian and vignerson
and in this model we have more than one
proverb
we have we we have many provers
but here here it's described only with
stopovers but it can be generalized of
course to many poverty so we have two
provers
a and b who claim that
the input x is in some language
l and the proof goes as follows
the verifier v sends a query q to a
and the query r to b there is
no interaction between a and b also for
now not even
quantum entanglement between a and b
and a needs to answer by an answer a
which is only a function of q and b by
an answer b
which is only a function of r and
based on q r a and b the verifier
decides whether to accept or
reject the the statement
that x is in l so this is
the model and what is really nice about
this model
is that there are very strong results
that are actually
the best that you could hope for more or
less so it's
uh by a buy for no loan
and actually for this you need to do it
in one round
round by five game and globals
actually for all this you you also need
the tcp
theorem because i i actually require
here also
efficiencies but
but okay so it's based on many works
so the protocol actually shows that
mip equals non-deterministic
exponential time here i scale it down
and and i only write it for languages
languages that can be computed in
deterministic time t of n
but it all works also for non-letter
meaning second just for this talk it's
important for me
the the deterministic time so let's
assume that
n can be computed in time t
of n well think again of t of n
either as polynomial time or up to
exponential
and again it can even be
nondeterministic but forget about this
for now
actually for this talk so there are
there
is a two provers multiprover interactive
proof
with the following requirement with the
following properties
so first we have a perfect completeness
so if and we are honest then the
probability that we accept is one
we have a sound is almost perfect one
minus negligible so the probability that
we
reject if actually x is not in l
is almost one no matter what the
progress
a and b do the running time of
both sb is polynomial in t of n
and the running time of the verifier is
a tilled
logarithmic factors is linear and also
if you want the communication it's
probably logarithmic
in the offense so so it's a a really
really good
delegation scheme except that it
delegates the computation
to two provers rather than one and you
assume you
that there is no communication between
the two proverbials
an assumption that in real life when you
delegate computation
to the cloud you cannot really assume
i assume so this is the protocol
and what a yellow at all suggested
is a way to use cryptography to reduce
the number of provers
back to one from two or even more powers
you can reduce the number of provers to
one so this is a suggested protocol i
will describe it
so what what yellow it all suggested is
is to start from a multiple interactive
proof
protocol and to translate it in into
what is called a one
round argument one round the protocol
with only one approval that is based on
computational sums
so suppose that in the original protocol
v sends q to a and r to b
and gets answer a from a and b
to b a from b so in the modified
protocol with only one prover
what we will do v the verifier will use
what is called
a fully homomorphic encryption
and will encrypt q and r using a fully
automorphic encryption
uh i'm not going to tell you what
exactly i'm not i'm not going to give
the definition of a foliomorphic
encryption but
the mechanism of a fully homomorphic
encryption
allows the prover to compute
a and b although the prover only sees
the encryption of q and r
so so this is the suggestion so p only
gets the encryption of q in the
encryption of r
and therefore it seems likely that p
cannot use r in order to compute a
and cannot use q in order to compute
b so again i don't want to get into
exactly what
is a fourier morphic encryption it's not
really important for the
rest of the talk but this was the
suggestion
uh yes so here you have to make the
assumptions that are behind the security
that's what there's some kind of a
security assumption yes exactly
exactly you need to assume that the fh
effigy cannot
be a broken is secure there was no
[ __ ] that's all back then there was no
effigy they suggested to you
to use peer scheme cryptographic peer
scheme and
everything i'm going to say also works
when you use a
cryptographic peer scheme the concept
was known in a long time
just that no one had a scheme but but
they
they did have pillscape back there the
yes the concept was known except i don't
know if people believe that the
protection exists
assumption that so the all the
cryptographic
schemes that we talk about must use some
cryptographic assumption because they
work so so you have a
computational assumption on the approval
that the problem is computationally
limited and in order to use that you you
need some cryptographic assumption so
for the cryptographic protocol
we need some cryptographic assumption we
need
the existence of a fully homomorphic
encryption scheme
but for the talk we will be able soon
enough to
forget about that
okay so
a so this was the suggestion and the
only problem is
that no one knows if it works or not
there is no proof that this actually
works
and no one could actually give even a
general enough
case in which this works
and our a starting point
actually is that if you assume
some additional requirement
additional soundness requirement if you
assume that the soundness of the
multipover interactive
protocol is stronger than what you add
then you can prove security of the
yellow at all
a yellow at all suggestion and this is
called
no signaling no signaling
strategies so we want our protocol our
original multi-pover interactive
protocol to be
secure to no signaling strategies and i
think maybe
these forums many people know what are
no signaling
strategies because they are related to
quantum computation and we will talk
about it later
so let me now give you the definition of
what is a no signaling strategy and this
is the definition with
two provers we will later on see the
definition for a larger number of
problems
so suppose that this is our original
protocol we send q to a r to b
and a answer by a b answer by b
now we think of the provers of
each proverb a supporter that can see
both inputs
a can see both q and r
and we can see both q and r and both of
them can also
see a common random string that they
share
and proven a answer by some function
of qr and z will cover the answers by
some function of q r and z
and they need to satisfy the following
requirements that are called the no
signaling requirements
one for each prover the first
requirement
is that conditioned on the query queue
for the first prover
the random variables a
and r are independent as random
variables so if we condition
on the question of the query that got
the first player
the answer of the first player doesn't
give
any information about the query
for the other for the other
problem and vice versa condition
on the input for the second forward
the answer of the second prover does not
give any information
about the query for
the first mover so this this is the no
signaling condition in two provers
actually
in k-provers uh
you this is the condition they're not
signaling a condition
for for k provers you require the same
for any subset any two subset of provers
so suppose that we have now k provers
that get queries q1 to qk
and give answers a1 to ak each ai
now is allowed to be a function of all
the queries
and of a common random string that all
the provers share
share and the requirement is that for
every subset s of queries
if you condition on all the queries to
this subset
then the answers of all the provers in
this subset
gives no information about the queries
to all the other problems so
this set of
answers is independent of this set of
queries
as random variables condition on this
set of queries
so this is the node signaling condition
and soundness against no signaling
condition
means that for any no signaling
strategies
if the input x is not in the language
end
then the probability that v rejects is
almost one so the verifier needs to
reject
not only classical strategies for the
k-popovers
but also the the verifier needs to
reject on
all no signaling strategies and this is
the stronger assumption
the no signaling assumption that we need
to assume
and if we assume this we can prove that
the the scheme of a yellow at all does
work so a
we we can prove that any multiple over
interactive proof
with no signaling soundness can be
translated
into one run government or another case
into a delegation scheme
a using the approach of
a yellow at all
actually we need soundness for almost no
signaling strategies
not only for no signaling strategy but
we need
soundness to strategies that are ex very
very close to no signaling this is even
stronger
but but this actually in all our proofs
when you perform
no no signaling you also see that the
proof actually works for almost no
signaling also
anyway one corollary of what we do
is that interactive proofs can be
translated into one round argument this
was known by
by a result of alkaline myself
but this gives a i would say a better
understanding
what we do now gives a better of an
understanding of
that proof actually it gives the
uh the right formalism to state that
but of course the real challenge is to
to see
what can to come up with new multiverse
interactive proofs
with no signaling soundness and
to use them to get one around the
negation schemes
and that's exactly what we do and let me
tell you now about
no signaling strategies i guess that yes
okay so how many non-signal improvers do
you need in your portfolio
okay okay
okay so uh let me tell you a little bit
about
no signaling strategies i'm sure that in
this form
many people know about that no signaling
interactions were studied in physics
long before multiple very interactive
proofs were defined
and this is because all interactions in
physics
are no signaling and they were also
studied as
in the case of multiple interactive
force in relation
to uh to multiple interactive forces
with entangled
probes so i guess by now more
all of you know what are multiple
interactive hopes with entangled
strategies we heard about it but in
general just to
repeat just review we have two provers a
and b that get classical queries q and r
does answer by classical answers a and b
but the two
proverbs share a common a quantum
state and before they answer each
proverb can measure
the his part of the state so they share
quantum entanglement and they use it
so these are in this case it's two
progress wheels
with a a sheldon tangled quantum state
and we say that multiple interactive
proofs
are sound against entangled strategies
if for any and tangent provers in this
case that i talk about k
provers if x the input is not in the
language
l then the probability that we reject is
close to one and they we
heard yes all of you heard yesterday
about the break four
from from two years ago by ito and vidiq
and then also by another paper by a
vidiq
that shows that multiple interactive
proofs with
entangled strategies content contains
nx actually i prefer to think about
mip star as say
classical protocols that are sound
against entangled strategies and then
this is
exactly next actually until yesterday it
was
in my slide i had equal here but i
i didn't want to freak out some people
in the audience because i
changed it but maybe we'll change it
back after the talk
um
so i'm talking about
i'm talking about classical protocol so
the completeness must be with classical
proverbs and then there is and then it's
known to be next
so that's what i'm saying hey but it's
not important
i can leave it
and so
no signal no signal okay so
so what is the relation between
entangled
provers and no singling no signaling
powers
so the the relation is that
entangled strategies are no signaling
and i i think that's the main reason
that
people studied it no signaling is an
easier mathematical condition and
all entangled the strategies are no
signaling
and this of course can be proved
mathematically but there is a strong
physical intuition and the physical
proof
i would say is that signaling means that
information can travel
faster than light because a
signaling strategy means that
the information passed instantly from
alice to bob if the output of
alice gives information about the input
of bob so actually this is from bob to
alice
but the information passes instantly
which means faster than light and we
know
by special relativity that information
cannot pass
faster than light and actually
a the no signaling principle stands in a
way
above quantum computation the
non-signaling
principle is likely to hold in
any future ultimate theory of physics
quantum theory is just a theory
and we know that it's not complete so
it's
possible at least actually i will love
to hear your opinion about that if it's
possible
that a future theory of physics
will have some what is called super
quantum
correlations that that are not
even cannot be modeled by entangled
states but by no signaling correlations
so if you prove no signaling a
soundness for your scheme
then this soundness is likely to
then your scheme is likely to er to
remain sound
even in any future physical
theory and not only in the current
quantum
theory that we have so i guess it all
depends on your standard of
standard of security so if you want to
remain secure in the future you have to
to use
no signal okay so what do we know about
no signaling soundness what do we know
about monty pover interactive folks with
no signaling soundness actually it was
studied
before us in several worlds
and it turns out that no signaling
cheater cheating provers
are very powerful so in particular we
know that
that multiple over in the classical
multiprover interactive also even
quantum even multiple very interactive
forces
entanglement with soundness against
entangled proverbs
is next but no signaling multiple
interactive proofs was known to be
between
x and p space and actually if you only
talk about
two provers then it was known to be
equal to p space
by a result by ito and this is a
both of these results are by a linear
programming
in particular it means that all the
all the known protocol protocols that
show
that multiple over interactive proofs
that map equals next cannot work
do not have no signaling soundness
yes in these equations and inequalities
are you
uh thinking of mip with um
classical completeness uh or with
quantum producers
i mean like on the outside quantum
well the definition in the completeness
do you assume like totally classical
machines or anything that can be no
signaling
for the weakness completeness of what
well
uh in in no signaling mip
i mean you you have the conditions you
have the um you have the completeness
and there the question is which set of
approvers are allowed there
i need no okay so so let's say that
there are
only classical okay in our protocol it
will be classical
so let's say that they allow only
classical so anything the point of
what i want to say that is that all
known proofs for
mip equals next next
do not have no signaling soundness and
this must be the case because
no signaling mip is contained in x
and all these proofs were for next
or if you want scaled down to a
np and many times it's really
so many times it's really easy to see
what is the no signaling strategy
that breaks the soundness and you can
see
i have in this example for xor games
where the verifier v sends q
to a r to b and gets the answer
a and b from a and b and suppose that
the only test that the verifier does is
to check that
x so b is some constant that depends on
q
and out so this is a song game but
in this particular case it's really easy
to give no signalling strategy
that that they actually for which the
verifier accepts this probability one
and this is the strategy a answers by
vqr z where z is a random b
and b answers by z and then the sort of
half of them is exactly the right value
although each of them is a random bit
even when you condition
on both inputs so this is
a this is an example and actually this
example generalized to very to
to many other multiple interactive ports
many times
all you need to do in order to find the
no signaling
strategy that breaks the scheme is
just to let the two provers or to the
many programs to give a random
assignment
that satisfies the verifier and this
works in many cases it will be in many
cases
no signaling strategy for which the
verifier
accepts so our result is
that no signalling multiple over
interactive proofs
equals x so actually i will
as i said our completeness will be
classical
but the soundness will be only will be
also against no signaling multiple
verbal interactive wars
and this is actually so this is a
actually the result is more general
for any language in time t of n
we give a multiple over interactive
proof with the following property
the running time of the provers will be
polynomial
in the offense and so the progress will
be efficient
the running time of the verifier will be
almost linear
till the o fn will tilt on oh
hides poly logarithmic factors so it's
poly logarithmic in t of n
n times polynomial the number of provers
is poly logarithmic in t of n
so even if t of n is x then it will be a
polynomial
number of provers but in particular if t
is polynomial
it will be poly logarithmic number of
provers the communication
is poly logarithmic and the completeness
the completeness of the protocol is one
with classical proverbs
and the soundness is against no
no signaling strategies with negligible
and
the soundness is with negligible error
um okay so this is the main result
for no signaling
and you can think of this result
also as a scheme to delegate computation
to a group of proverbs
that
that are not that can apply any no
signaling strategy
and this uh i'm sorry
sorry so i want to insist on this
on this many times i have a reason for
asking
so are these things streaming algorithms
are these the verifiers do they read
from left to right
because for example if you have two
tapes and you read from left to right
and you do it just
logarithmically many times then
okay so the stronger result that we have
at least as
as far as we understand it maybe you can
tell me later
the stronger result that we have is that
the
the verifier doesn't even need to know
the input
the i mentioned it before but the
verifier only needs to know
one point in the loading extension
one or if you want a little bit more
than one
a point in the low degree extension of
the input which is some error collecting
code of the input so the logical
extension
can be computed by streaming so
you can with one pass on the input
compute this
uh this one point or if the verifier
gets this 1.43
the verifier doesn't need to know
anything else
so it doesn't even need to read the
input
if if you know this point for free and
then the running time
of the verifier is only poly logarithmic
does this answer the question
very far the very fire only needs to
know
a point or some small number of points
in the low degree extension of the input
okay okay so this is the result
you can think of it as say delegating
computation
to a group of no signaling provers
um so you want us to think of mip star
as as uh cla as classical provers but
the proofs are are secure against
quantum
entangled provers so i'm talking about
no signaling i know but
but you say that this is basically a
strengthening
of a result that mit star according to
your definition equals
x equals nx our result
yes it's incomparable it shows that
that with multiple interactive
proofs with no signaling soundness is x
not next x that's the
so it's only for x and it cannot be
improved
exactly yes but but but but this is only
for
x then the results for for entanglement
is for
nx for exponential
that it contains expire this is an
another performance
in particular yes yes it gives soundness
against some tangled folders in
particular
as a special case
okay
but only through your results
yes okay
yes it wasn't known more than two years
ago
yes in particular it proves that that
multiple
that you can have a protocol with
multiple interactive proofs
uh with entangled provers for an a4x
sorry not for the nx so you can think of
it
as delegating competition for a group of
proverbials
with no signaling that can have no
signaling
strategies i think of it as delegating
competition to the martians
the martians are amazing engineers
they constructed quantum compute a
quantum computer in their prehistory
already they
build iphones in kindergarten
and last week they announced the new
computer it's called the x
time machine it runs any x time
computation
in one second and
we on earth want to delegate all our
computation to the martians
all our competitions of the martian but
we don't trust them
also we don't know maybe they have
higher physics than ours so
we don't trust that they only have a
quantum entanglement
and this gives a way to delegate
competition to the martians you take
k martians you put them in different
points
in space and you ensure that there is no
communication between them
by just by sending them the queries
and expect the answers to arrive a
little bit
like almost in the speed of light so
they don't have time to
communicate between them they might have
no signalling
interactions between them but still
you're guaranteed
that the proof is uh
correct so this gives a scheme as i said
to do that with polynomial
quality number of uh sorry the running
time of the provers is
quality the running time of the verifies
and polynomial
the number of provers is polynomial a
number of uh yeah it's written twice
and the completeness is one the
soundness is against no signaling
strategies okay
i want to tell you about the proof but i
will tell you about
the first step which can also be
considered as a result
and the result is about what we call
no signaling pcps so the first step of
the proof is to switch from mip to pcp
the result is about what we call
non-signaling pcp
and let me tell you what is a no signal
in pcp in a standard pcp we have a
verifier that
reads the classical pcp in k
places in what we call no signal in pcp
so usually in a standard pcp a classical
pcp
there is some bit written in each of
them
in a in a non-signaling pcp for every
subset s of locations
up to some global parameter that we call
k
there is a distribution a s and when the
verifier
queries dislocations the verifier gets
some vector of answers which is
distributed
according to the distribution
aes and the only guarantee is that for
any s1 and s2 that are smaller
than the global parameter k this
parameter will be poly log t
uh so for any two sets that are smaller
than the global parameter
the two distributions must agree on the
intersection
so this so this is uh what we call no
signaling pcp
so when the verifier queries k queries
the verifier gets some
answers that are given according to some
distribution it can be different
distribution for
every set of queries but they must agree
on the intersection
as long as both sets are smaller than
the global parameter than polynomial yes
sorry to grill the intersection yes the
the projection
so if you if you take a
according to s1 and then you restrict to
the intersection you get the same as
as if you think according to s2 and
restrict to the
what other intersection are queried yes
yes
exactly and what we prove
is actually a pcp theory with no
signaling soundness
is that but only for deterministic
computation for
for any alien time t of n we have a pcp
with the following properties the
running time of the prover
is polynomial empty the running time of
the person
actually creates the pcp the running
time of the verifier is almost linear
the number of queries is poly
logarithmic
and this is also the global parameter k
and the completeness is one and the
soundness is against
most signaling strategies as i define
themselves
sorry and so suppose you um
you know asked a slightly different
question which is uh
given such uh local distributions
are they are they consistent with the
global distribution what's the
complexity of that
okay so that's it
okay so so so i didn't require that
there is a global distribution that they
are all consistent with
and that's their point i understand but
um
so you're asking if i get the
distributions
so is that a hard problem
yes i think so yeah so when you when you
do
hierarchies of sdps you get these
often local distributions right right
and finding the global distributions and
people
so but here you are sort of you you're
somehow making sure
that uh
so so k is poly log t the number of
distributions
is a n choose poly log t or something
like that
and if you allow running time polynomial
in this you can
you can check whatever you want
okay so that's the result about pcp
that's it
so just to clarify this result about no
signaling provers equally
next or sorry x um so
there was just one round of
communication with approvers is that
correct
yes and okay and the number of approvers
was poly log t so
yes so polylog so how many provers do
you need to get
x i guess is the question a polynomial
number or polynomial okay
okay we don't know how to do it with
smaller number of robbers it cannot be
done with stopovers
yeah because it's space so somewhere
between two and polynomial is this yes
the answer just for our cryptographical
result we don't
need a polynomial number of covers is
perfect
it's perfectly fine for us so
we don't need that but but anyway
we we don't know how to do it with less
progress
thanks oh yes um
can you explain the intuition why the
security against um
non-signal improvers was related to the
security proof of the
usage of homomorphic encryption kind
so what happened there is that
the verified the power got a q and
r encrypted and the proof of security
more or less says
that if um
okay so so now suppose that there is a
prover that that breaks this scheme
so so the proverb gets q encrypted and
and are encrypted and gives a and b
encrypted
so the point is that since okay so main
i'm not sure if they said that but q and
r are encrypted with different keys
so if the prover actually breaks the
scheme
then then if you
if if you know one of the keys you
cannot queue
and and and then you get
you get information between r and the
output so
it's it's not that hard i have it on two
slides but i remove them
it takes two minutes maybe
is it possible that you briefly tell you
tell us the relation between how you
went from mit
non-signaling to non-signaling pcp
so this is actually not not that odd
this is actually not that hard
you just define so if you have a
multiple very interactive forms
you just define this distribution
so you think of each of each query to
the pcp
as a query to one of the programs but
you do like a symmetrization over all
the
possibilities say for sending it to the
problems
so so the number of four wells should be
k
and you ask this to one over this to
another this or another but
you do have under permutation between
the problems and then if you have a
strategy for the four verse you can
define a strategy for the epcp
so so we prove sum is against the
signaling tcps and now we want to prove
that
that there is some is for no signal
improvers
so if we have if we assume for a
contradiction that there isn't
no signaling strategies for the profile
we want to define
no significant strategy for the pcp and
you do it just by symmetrization just by
uh
taking this two random progress
permutations